that mindset that embraces failure how
do you
personally i mean that it
that those kinds of failures would drive
a lot of us in this room
nuts but doesn't seem to drive you nuts
seems like you're very comfortable with
it
can you talk about the mindset that
requires for you to be that
accepting of that kind of failure uh
sure what should we roll the video
no should we not no we should not roll
the video not yet
okay okay um
okay um well i think of the
these things is just there's a certain
amount of time
and within that time you want the
the best net outcome so for
you know all the set of actions that you
can do there's
going to be uh and some of which will
fail some which will succeed
and you want the the the net useful
output of your set of actions to be the
highest
um so
um like use like a baseball analogy like
you know baseball they don't let you
just sit there and wait for the perfect
pitch
until that you get a real easy one they
didn't give you
three shots and then the third one they
say okay and they
get off the they go back to the put
somebody else up there
um so these your three strikes on on the
baseball
um not you know not
only bad anymore so so
you what you're really looking for is
like what's the batting average
you know how you doing on
on score and just
there's going to be some amount of
failure
but you want your net output um
net useful output to be maximized
failure is
essentially irrelevant unless it is
catastrophic
okay yeah